guys been working with robert zemeckis
for many many years now lots of
different movie projects how did the
flight experience compare well flight
was a terrific experience for us and as
you say we worked many many many years
together and the flight was a wonderful
experience for all of us it was hard it
was tough it had its challenges as they
all do but we loved the screenplay and
that's what drives all of our passions
yeah it really felt like going back to
the old days because we've been involved
in big scale digital cinema and all of a
sudden we got this screenplay that
demanded that you Ratchet back
everything you've been doing back to
those old live-action but really you
know a really tight schedule tight
budget and you know it's a real crafty
film which we had in our hip pocket you
know it's like riding a bike you
remember how to do that even though it
was the old days and it felt really good
to kind of roll up your sleeves and kind
of get dirty again and get down in the
trenches and shoot enjoy what experience
I'm having as you say you've it involved
in lots of kind of CG how many mocap
things like a Christmas Carol Polar
Express bear wolf as well going back to
that live-action filmmaking you know you
walk on a set you see it all dressed and
the actors are in wardrobe and you know
the camera is there and you're getting
the coverage and that's all great I mean
we're used to living our lives when we
had to imagine everything every day it's
like that guys running around and where
is he and you're just like oh yeah what
was it like because I see and you know
Robert Zemeckis has got experience of
the pilot himself what did he add to it
do you feel an expertise I mean really I
mean there wasn't gonna it was gonna all
be truth truthful because he wasn't
gonna do anything that he didn't think
could really happen but and you knew
mechanically exactly you know nothing
was doing a movie about doctors he would
have done the same research and been as
facile with the material as it is that
he's you know pilot now of course as he
said before you put lots of Robert
thinking about photos it might be coming
up we've heard that yellow
Marine isn't happening right now but kid
we look forward to maybe that happening
at some time in the future and what
about Who Framed Roger Rabbit
the sequel that's equals gonna get may
trust me
yeah I mean we have a great script we're
just trying to pull it together and see
if we can pull it off but we're ready to
go if somebody says go over there as far
as Yellow Submarine you know right now
it's it was a project that came and went
right now it's dead but we still love
the songs and music and the Beatles all
right long live the Beatles you G visit
Connie having that bob hoskins role now
that unfortunately he's no longer acting
well you know it is troublesome but you
know we last had lunch with him we'll
figure out a way with digital technology
there's always a way to get a guy on his
feet and he's ready to do it
you